chances are you've seen shangela on
almost every red carpet including last
weekend's 91st Academy Awards I'm
calling it right now 2019 is the year of
shangela shangela first appeared on the
second season of RuPaul's Drag Race
after doing drag for only five months
unfortunately shangela was the first
Queen eliminated but surprised shangela
returned for the following season of the
show placing six shangela no one can say
you didn't try your hardest and it's
that drive that will take you far Libya
dreams mama I'm leaving a winner and
it's just a lesson for everyone who's
ever wanted to pursue any dream they've
had live your passion and live it to the
fullest Paula loop but shangela time on
drag race wasn't over she came back
again on the third season of RuPaul's
Drag Race all-stars I'm gonna keep my
head up imma keep it pushing and I will
keep working my story is not over that
over I keep going no shade to Trixie who
won all-stars three but even Michelle
visage agrees I think the biggest
surprise to me and the rest of the world
was shangela not winning RuPaul's Drag
Race all-stars three and that wasn't up
to me that wasn't up to RuPaul that was
up to the girls they chose not to put
shangela in there and I personally what
was a mistake but I also believe that
they did it because of a personal
relationship instead of watching how she
did in the competition since first
appearing on drag race shangela has been
one of the busiest Queens to come from
the runa verse she has built quite the
demo reel that includes appearances on
hit series like The X Files Glee and two
Broke Girls got ready no girl I got you
I'm gonna make you a fresh batch
hallelujah could I have some fresh -
you'll get the burnt ones and like it
nerd in 2013 shangela was one of the
queens who appeared in Lady Gaga's lyric
video for applause
[Music]
shangela was then handpicked by Lady
Gaga to audition for a role in a star is
born after auditioning they were so
blown away with shangela they actually
gave her a larger role in the film
shangela who was friends with Frankie
grande went to studio with him one night
while Ariana was recording her latest
album Thank You next while visiting the
Zach sang show Ariana explained how
shangela ended up kicking off the song
NASA when she came to visit the studio
when we were making NASA and she was
like she was that girl this is one small
step for woman one giant leap for
womankind and I was like you needed to
say that again right now and that's
going at the beginning of the record she
was like oh girl hold on let me get
ready and I was like you're not on
camera it's just your voice so funny at
the 2019 film Independent Spirit Awards
shangela surprised the crowd of a list
stars with a hilarious performance what
would she say
and just last weekend shangela became
the first drag queen to walk the Academy
Awards red carpet along with her BFF
Jennifer Lewis prior to walking shangela
tweeted I'm up early I couldn't sleep
I'm like a kid waiting for Christmas
morning this is going to be a historic
day for me I'm probably gonna cry
a lot I still can't believe it I'm going
to the Oscars I'm going to the Oscars
I'm going to the Oscars I think just
being here today is a true testament
that anyone in this world not only are
you do you belong are you valid but also
you have a place and it starts with
accepting yourself you know when I came
to find you know that I really accepted
myself and love who I was then the sky
was the limit shangela is living proof
that if you have a dream follow it no
matter how crazy that dream may be or
how many times you fall you get right
back up shangela appearing at mainstream
events like the Academy Awards and in
the film a star is born matters why
because representation matters and
shangela is a fabulous representative of
the LGBTQ community and is continuing to
keep the conversation going
do you agree with me and think shangela
is on track to be a massive star in 2019
what other drag race Queens do you think
will find success which Queen do you
want to see on your TV and in films let
me know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe to ET Canada's
YouTube page
you